Turkish president
is starting the first day of his third
term in office he beat his rival Kamal
khalitch the rolu in an election runoff
on Sunday he won more than 52 percent of
the vote it's been described as one of
the most important in decades his rival
killitch derolu got 48 let's go to
cinema castiolu who's live for us in
Istanbul in a neighborhood with Syrian
refugees Cinema do people there think
erdogan is going to keep his campaign
promises which were about repatriating
Syrian refugees back home
well in this neighborhood called Fati
one of the historical neighborhoods of
Istanbul is the primary initial location
Syrian refugees came when they started
to flee to Turkey from the civil war in
Syria starting from 2011 and where I'm
standing used to be an old Bazaar even
with a decades ago for many Turkish
residents living here now most of the
shops here are owned by the syrians they
are usually entrepreneurs they're
Tradesmen
and they when they settle in a
neighborhood they like to create their
own shopping areas or business centers
let me say yes in Turkey the Syrian
refugees are are not able to buy
properties and after staying here for
five years they are eligible to apply
for a Turkish passports Turkish
citizenship and most of them do support
president erdogan but they have been
very unhappy about the far-right
Nationalist discourse that have been
calling to repatriate them send them
back to their homes for the last one and
a half years and that sentiment was
actually first provoked and promoted by
Victory party leader
umit ojda who had aligned with camachus
for the second round after their
candidate allied with President erdogan
I must say that they are not happy but
of course for for the syrians who who
received Turkish citizenship it is not
possible to go back if they want to stay
they will be saying they cannot the
Ankara cannot rip off their citizenship
yesterday when Ardon was delivering his
balcony speech he mentioned that so far
600 000 Syrian refugees
voluntarily return to their homes to
areas that are controlled by the
opposition backed by the Turkish
military mainly in Northern Syria and he
said turkey and Qatar made a deal signed
a deal and they are they will be
creating a safe environment a housing
area for the Syrian refugees who want to
return and within the first couple of
years Ankara promises to send back at
least 1 million Syrian refugees back to
their homes will it be possible we don't
know because for them for a safe return
there should be peace there shouldn't be
any bombings they should be totally
assured by the Damascus government as
well but of course syrians are not happy
at being at the center of an election
campaign that promises to send them all
back Molly and what can we expect from
president erdogan now on the
international stage
well presents are done once uh promised
for an accession to the EU and for that
achieving all the necessary reforms
asked by the European union now in a way
turned its back to West I mean they
comprehend he turned his back but this
is also his strategic partnership with
Russia in Syria in Libya in caraba
that's why it seems Ankara is split
between West between NATO and Russia and
many of his critics and the opposition
party has promised that if they had come
to power they would be aligning they
will be turning their faces back to
Europe but of course president argon
never leaves aligning with Europe either
but definitely he will continue for an
independent defense defense industry
Trend that provides a turkey new
warships a local produce warships local
produce drones local produce helicopters
and planes so this will definitely
continue his friends Caspian and turkic
States Alliance will continue but he
will need to hedge the regional
geographical risks with the economic
risk that he's facing right now like the
skyrocketing inflation in the country
Molly thank you for that surname because
you're there for us live in Istanbul